but Elon buys Twitter they got 7 500  employees  immediately he cuts 50 so go to 37.50  they cut 37.50 the 37.50 that were cut  recruit the other 1200 to quit so 37.50  gets another 1200 so he's not lost 5 000  okay Twitter goes from 7 500 employees  to 2500 employees and Twitter's done  more advancement in the last two months  of additional things on Twitter that  you've seen the last two three years now  what do you like the features or not  it's irrelevant it's things are being  updated right it's like quickly things  are being updated Twitter went from  being a slow large you know a social  government social media company to now  it's going back to the startup things  moving very very quickly right